welcome to metaphysical military shakers
welcome to this next episode i'm your
host rayne wilson
and
welcome
reza aslan who's also a host of this
show
sorry that was awkward that's kind of my
thing reza you are definitely awkward
you are definitely you've always been
awkward
you are an awkward human being
i i feel bad there was a show title
taken called awkward because that really
is the story of my life awkward the rain
wilson story exactly the the and proof
of this was right before this session i
was
online practicing my chess um
my uh rui lopez attack and my king's
indian defense oh jesus which i you know
i mix up king's indian and the perk
defense they're very similar it's the
same idea it's about fianchetto bishops
you know it's about seeding the
ownership of the central
squares but really developing a late
game it's sometimes called the modern
game
i don't think i don't think we can
afford to lose any more of our listeners
than we are already losing as as you
continue
to talk about your geek
nerdness
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
you went through a nerd phase too right
i mean you this is this is part of your
heritage listen i'll tell you the
difference between you and me rain
wilson and this is actually i really
admire this about you i really do we
haven't talked about this before we're
planning on this but i i really admire
this about you which is that every time
you tell a story about your childhood
uh
it is
unflinchingly honest about your
absolute acceptance
of your uh like nerdness
you know very true you were a nerd
you were a weird-looking dude and you
just that's who you were and you just
kind of accepted it and you moved along
and i i can't
say with the straight face that i felt
the same way because i too
was a weirdo and a nerd i mean i didn't
speak english that well and i'm like
this brown dude
uh
and i'm and i'm here at a time in which
like you know it's like the early 1980s
not the best time uh to be in iranian in
america
uh and yet
instead of
accepting that instead of just simply
kind of
you know absorbing that i i spent a good
part of my childhood running away from
it pretending to be cool pretending to
be hip pretending to be a jock and i am
not cool i am not hip and i am not a
jock i you know this i even pretended to
be mexican
for like a good decade
i didn't know that was your story
i you pretended to be like reza
hernandez or i did no you just used
their names it kind of sounds i actually
it's like resa is a is a spanish word
it's like the imperative uh it means
pray so people thought i was just a
really really religious mexican you know
i think you and i both felt like
outsiders
when we were growing up but i admire the
fact that uh
as far as you know what i know about you
like you you didn't run away from that
you you absorbed it and i feel like i
spent you know pretty much all of
elementary school junior high certainly
most of high school
running away from my
outsider geek nerd
true self
and it wasn't until college that i was
like you know what [ __ ] you guys i i
this is who i am and then and i embraced
it i'm gonna make a living out of it
that's fantastic well you know
this is an important conversation
because i feel like with this mental
health crisis with young people today
kind of people embracing
their mental health difficulties
embracing who they are embracing their
awkwardness
their nerdiness whatever else about them
feels different and unaccepted and to
allow that to transform into a
superpower yeah and
we have a guest on the show i'm so
excited to bring on the show because
he more than anyone else i know has
managed to do this he turned um
a kind of tragic youthful story
um that could have uh left a weaker
person broken
but in embracing his weakness and
vulnerability and brokenness has made an
entire
career out of it so
will wheaton is with us will wheaton
we're talking about will wheaton yes
not will wheaton
wesley crusher from star trek the next
generation gordy from stand by me that's
who we're talking about here
that's exactly what we're talking about
he's also a member of mensah
he is one of the very first bloggers
of all of all time
uh he's an active dungeons and dragons
player he still hosts uh an after show
about
uh star trek called the ready room
and uh so we're talking about a
certified
geek like
you like in the in the pantheon
of geek
we would find will be you know listen
listen there's there's a lot of geeks
out there there's people who claim to be
geeks they talk about it there's shows
about it there's networks about it
there's gamers there's there's dorks and
and whatnot but he has transformed his
geekdom into something truly
transcendent and the reason that we
wanted to have will wheaton on this show
besides the fact that he's awesome in
almost every way is that exactly what
you were talking about like nowadays
sure you're a geek and you're celebrated
the geeks shall inherit the earth blah
blah blah but man
not in the 80s let me tell you something
not when will wheaton was growing up and
uh you know will he's got this amazing
book called still just a geek
that we're going to talk about a little
bit but
part of the reason why we wanted to have
him on this show is because
his story is such an inspiring story
of
never losing sight of who you really are
embracing your identity embracing
the person that you are
even when the world just shits on you
for it even when the entire world tells
you
you suck be something else
will is the perfect example
of
saying to the world
[ __ ] you
this is who i am and i am so stoked to
have him on the show so please
without further ado welcome will wheaton
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh my god it's will wheaton i can't even
believe it i'm having trouble breathing
right now buddy temba his arms wide yes
yes i'm wearing my dharmak enchilada
tanagra shirt by the way i want to start
this uh podcast
by outing my
fake geek star trek fan co-host rayne
wilson who was like what's a darmok and
i was like oh my god rain you're not a
fake geek because you don't know who
darmock is it just means you haven't
seen that episode it doesn't mean he's
it sounds like a poncho you you would
buy in bolivia well uh we don't need to
tell you this uh we are gigantic uh fans
of yours i've been a fan of yours
forever i uh am not you know i'm not
embarrassed to say that i'm a die hard
tracker i've been a trekker for
pretty much since i was like i think a
sophomore in high school i believe is is
when it when it began so this is a very
special uh moment for me because i've
i've actually never uh talked to anyone
who's been on any star trek uh episode
of any kind so this is really really
excuse me
uh rain what what is it yes rain wilson
you have your hand raised you said you
have not talked to anyone who has ever
been on any star trek episode ever
you wanna
hello i'm i'm the reboot of harry mudd
oh right right right right right um how
did you manage to navigate the delicate
uh
sensibilities surrounding the mud's
women trope when you recreated the
character
they put them in prison is what they did
that's how they dealt with that
there's a joke i don't know if this is
true there is an apocryphal story that
in the early years of next generation
someone had an idea that the enterprise
would come across kind of a derelict
ship somewhere and there was a life form
on board that was in stasis pull the
life form off wake him up and when he
wakes up
he says where am i and dr crusher says
you're on the enterprise and he goes oh
come on and it's harry mudd who's been
like in stasis forever it's a really
lovely idea um uh that we weren't able
to do because the actor who played him
had died um like like somebody like
planted the seed for the idea and i
guess the guy was like nope i'm dying
and uh and and sorry i'm dying over here
literally the great roger carmel uh hats
off to him uh such an exquisite uh actor
i only did two uh episodes as um
as harry mudd in uh star trek discovery
that's std
yeah um
i am a huge fan of tos the original
series tos
and uh loved harry mudd as a child and
what an honor to get to shoot a phaser
and to sit in a captain's chair and to
get beamed up and to ride an elevator to
the bridge and
and all of that mishmash uh was a dream
come true so
did you have uh did you struggle with uh
so that couple of times i got to fire a
phaser and i hear this happens all the
time with people who regularly fire
phasers is there's this um
uh if it were real it would be very much
just like i pushed the button right but
when we do it sure because we grew up
watching star trek we're like pew pew
you know we're like you know like
creating points
and and there are there are these
stories of actors running around the
star trek sets making pew pew noises
just
because it's i think it activates some
kind of like child memory uh that just
takes over
um but when you got the fire phaser what
but it's cool right i mean it's you're
just holding a prop but you're firing a
face or like it's super cool right it's
super cool it's super cool i did not
make the pew pew pew
sounds well of course
uh
it was it was a dream come true i hope
to someday in some other
form or respect either bring that
character back or
reappear in some star trek iteration but
um maybe maybe that's it but either
either way i can die happy but i was a
huge the original series fan in fact i'm
writing this new book um
called soul boom
why we need a spiritual revolution
and i have the whole first chapter is a
comparison between the two greatest 70s
television shows star trek and kung fu
as mirror uh parallel
spiritual journeys the kung fu is the
internal
journey of the the emotional journey of
the wayfarer going on his quest
you know overcoming obstacles dealing
with temptations with good and evil and
star trek being the the journey of
humanity as a whole where you know
science has liberated us from hate from
prejudice and has um is guiding us
technologically forward into the
universe to to meet our our fellows um
in create bonds of of love and unity um
and that that's where mankind is
ultimately headed if we don't destroy
ourselves i like to think that we're
headed in a star trek direction so
uh we're huge trekkers
anyways we wanted to talk to you about
your new book still just a geek you had
a book just still just a game
i feel like we i think i feel like we
spent a good ten minutes sort of
clarifying our geek bona fides and now
now
we are at the place where we can now
speak about geekdom
well said
now a word from our sponsor better help
people are feeling burnout more than
ever i know i am
uh
it's
a lot of work a lot of different
pressures coming at us and me from all
different sides
some of you might even be burned out
without even knowing it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
irritability fatigue and more
we associate burnout with work but
that's not the only cause
and better help wants to help it's
online therapy and it wants to remind
you to prioritize yourself talking with
someone else can help you figure out
what is causing stress in your life
because that's another big part for me
is my personal weekly therapy with bruce
my therapist bruce i highly suggest the
act of opening your heart sharing your
feelings examining your behavior
patterns with a seasoned professional
that can help guide you
and that's what better help provides
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist like
bruce in under 48 hours
our listeners get percent off their
first month at betterhelp.com
milkshake that's betterhelp.com
milkshake listen folks
take care of yourself okay don't uh
don't ignore the the warning signs all
right call better help
you know rain uh you and i both live in
california so you've seen the alerts
like i've seen the alerts were
in the middle of yet another drought
i mean this is the new normal i mean if
you're like me one of these people who
stresses a lot about you know climate
change and
the things that you can do in order to
at least personally
act responsibly and perhaps
alleviate
the impact that we are having on the
climate well
ren
is the company for you
ren is a startup that's making it easy
for everyone to make a meaningful
difference in the climate crisis
right now they're focused on monthly
subscriptions where you can calculate
your carbon footprint and then offset it
by supporting awesome climate projects
their goal is to unlock the collective
action of millions of individuals to
drive the systemic change needed to end
the climate crisis ren is a website
where you can calculate your personal
carbon footprint based on your lifestyle
then offset it by funding projects that
plant trees protect rainforests
sequester co2 and more signing up for
wren is an easy way to do something
meaningful about the climate crisis wren
practices hyper transparency once you
sign up to make a monthly contribution
to offset your carbon footprint you'll
receive monthly updates about the tree
planting rainforest protection and
carbon removal projects you're funding
you can even see the exact coordinates
of the trees you planted look folks it's
going to take all of us to end the
climate crisis so do your part today
sign up for ren go to ren
dot co slash milkshake
sign up and you know what they'll plant
10 extra trees in your name that's ren
w-r-e-n
dot
c-o
slash milkshake start making a
difference thank you ren
so uh will you the the book still just a
geek you you
call yourself uh a geek you proudly
self-describe uh as a as a geek tell us
how did you uh come to that realization
how did you realize that uh that you
were a geek or did someone have to tell
you which is often how it works right
i'll be 50 in july so i'm kind of like
in the middle of generation x and
my school yard experience was uh being
smart was really looked down on uh
caring about education and wanting to
learn was mocked and belittled um
it almost seemed like the the crucible
of the elementary school playground was
entirely it was it was like just lord of
the flies at my school right like the
big tough kids were just
they ran the place and and and um um i
and i don't know like four other kids
um one of whom i'm relatively confident
was on the spectrum in retrospect um
were just cerebral and we loved books
and we were not athletic or coordinated
and in the late 70s and early 80s when i
was in elementary school that kind of
uh focus and and enthusiasm wasn't
really celebrated the way it is now sort
of everywhere you go
and um kids made fun of us and called us
nerds and we were ashamed of it but like
you know
we would get together and
talk all about the thing we had seen on
star trek or that that episode of
thundar the barbarian we watched
saturday morning or what was happening
in someone's dnd game you know that's
he-man still ripped off thunder the
barbarian i will die on that hill
forever i will die on the hill forever
yeah he-man ripped off thunder the
barbarian um but like you know there was
just it was just this way of saying in
the sec when i was a kid calling
somebody a nerd or a geek was a way of
saying like oh you're you're different
you're weird you're maybe neurodivergent
you're intellectual you have weird
social skills you're awkward um and
you're really really really smart
because you spend all your time in your
head because when you're out of your
head people are making fun of you um
there was a point in my life uh where i
just decided i'm owning that i'm not
being ashamed of that and i'm gonna make
what was that what was that point when
was that point
i feel like are we talking 14 are we
talking 24 oh god i wish it was 14 no it
wasn't until i was in my 20s it was
definitely definitely when i was in my
20s and uh uh and and i started seeing
it was around the time that i feel like
the lord of the rings phenomenon really
mainstreamed a lot of what made our
culture our culture and i'm really
excited and really happy about that i
was thrilled about that when it happened
so i was starting to see people uh who
just
were not my people at comic con and
that's when i knew oh they're coming
they're coming into our community
cool the community is expanding and i've
been here since the very beginning i'm
not going to be ashamed of this there
are kids in this world who are thrilled
and enthusiastic and excited and they
feel ashamed of it and we who have like
um uh cleared the minefield ahead of
them
absolutely need to show them the path
through it and i was probably in my
early 20s when i just thought yeah man
it's great being a nerd is awesome let's
let's like let's love it and that was
around the time that i started
thinking uh about the concept and this
is in the book that being a nerd is not
about the thing that you love it's about
the way you love the thing right like
uh a
a football fan who goes to a a playoff
game in the middle of winter when it's
snowing in like a t-shirt and body paint
because they love their football team is
no different than somebody getting
dressed up for the 501st and going to a
comic convention it's the exact same
love it comes from the exact same place
digging into statistics and and looking
at the history is a note of of a sport
is no different than looking into the
lore of a video game absolutely or the
lore of an arg and just consuming it and
loving it and then celebrating it with
other people when i realized
in my 20s that this was something to be
celebrated that was awesome
um it it really it it changed the way
that i saw myself and it removed a lot
of the shame and hesitancy that i had
had experienced and i just thought i
want to make sure that as
as many people in the future can avoid
that sense of shame that we all kind of
grew up with
well so you just kind of went back and
forth between
geek and nerd i i noticed and i i'm
curious like what
what exactly is the difference i mean
what is a geek is it a nerd or is it a a
dweeb is it a spaz
is it a dork do we but i haven't heard
it in a really long time loser dog
reminds me of neo maxi zoom dweeby from
uh
uh the breakfast club yeah um i i i use
them interchangeably um really they
don't mean different things they're not
different categories not to me they
they're i'm sure that there are people
who would passionately argue i'm not a
geek i'm a nerd or the or i'm not a nerd
i'm a geek but it's kind of like the
trekkie trekker debate right like by
allowing people who aren't part of our
culture to say no trekkie is weird we
let them take that away from us and we
invented trekker so we could feel cool
about it [ __ ] that it's our culture it's
our love it's what we celebrate we're
calling ourselves trekkies deal with it
i'm not going to be ashamed about it um
i i i think that's i don't know i kind
of want to roll into to um
like muggle world with that sort of
energy like yo we're here let's you know
let's celebrate this cool weird stuff
um we're going to go for our favorite
geek moments i want to hear reza's here
in a minute personal my personal
favorite geek moments yeah i mean here's
here's mine here's here's mine there's
my crowning achievement of geekdom so in
my sophomore year of high school will i
want you to drink this in yeah okay i
was on the chess team
uh-huh i was on the computer club
i played bassoon in the orchestra yeah i
was on the debate team
and modeled united nations
and i did everything i wanted to do
i i was playing xylophone in the
marching band while wearing a kilt
because we were the shorecrest
highlanders
dude
that is so cool and it probably made you
really uncool at the time right i was
the uncool oh my god
of pimply skinny garbage
in north seattle that you'd ever want to
meet
but here's my cr here's the crowning
achievement
was our chess team went to the state
championships i was fourth board as a
sophomore i had nothing but as a
sophomore that's okay i as i had nothing
i had a big big dreams and hopes and
dreams in front of me and then
we came in we had
uh i forget i i forget we didn't win at
state but we do we did like okay i don't
we're like and then we came in and there
was a giant banner that said congrats
shortcrest chess team
for winning state or something we didn't
win state but there was this banner and
we all like walked in together i forget
why we were all together and we saw the
banner we're like
oh my god this is incredible they're
they're saluting us and our achievement
this is incredible and then it was a
bunch of the cheerleaders that had made
the banner and they saw us seeing the
banner and they all started to laugh oh
they started to laugh at john hughes
movie they're like
and we all dejectedly
went
our way um including jeff shadow who got
a letter
the jeff shadow
they even got jeff [ __ ] out those awful
mean girls wow they but he had a
letterman's jacket in chess so it said
shortcrust highlanders and it had a
chess piece and he proudly wore his
letterman's chest jacket
around the school so there you have it
reza you're up i there's no beating that
i feel like you should have gone last
all right here we go uh okay mine
okay mine was in college
uh so i was a freshman in college and
since we already brought up uh dharmark
and jalad uh then let's let's stay let's
stick with that theme um
so uh i'm studying uh world religions i
decide that that's what that's what i'm
gonna do like mythologies the religions
of the world people's beliefs legends
and all that stuff and um and everyone
has to do
this like presentation um
in our in our world mythology course
and
i decide
that what i'm gonna do is
a kind of
one-man kind of live reading of dharmak
and gelada tanagra
and so i
i
i fortunately here's the the good news
is i already had the captain's uniform
so i didn't have to go and get one that
was that was right so i already had the
picard uniform
um and i kind of beamed in to the front
of the class uh with my with my
communicator
uh and i
i yeah i basically
did a kind of 15 minute version like a
one-act
one-man play
uh type 15 of next year 15 of that
particular episode one of the greatest
episodes of all time
uh and then i and then i kind of you
know extrapolated from it and talked
about
um
the role of myth and metaphor
uh and and you know the the the idea
about how uh
uh
you know religion is essentially just
like a language of symbols and metaphors
and you have to you have to unpack the
symbols and metaphors now i will say
this was a very geeky moment and when it
was finished i had maybe like 20
students just stare
glassy-eyed at me like no one knew what
the hell i was talking about i did get
an a
no one knew
what i was talking about uh but
i got the last laugh on those bastards
because number one uh that became the
foundation for
uh
my uh eventually my dissertation and
sort of uh
my life's work and the way that i talk
and and think about religion and what
religion is
and then
a few years ago i had the opportunity to
go on um
i guess what is the the like one of the
official star trek pod or something
uh and and spent 45 minutes essentially
just presenting the entire thesis of
dharmak and jalad and how
it was uh it was the platform through
which i built my entire uh career as a
thinker about
religion so no xylophone no no uh
bassoon
if i
there was a vote there's a xylophone and
bassoon in that story i feel like i
would have won but uh that's that's my
geek story
some things are inevitable like allergy
season
sorry
listen if you're like me
you you are feeling it right now the
weather's changing
my allergies are killing me i mean i
normally sound like a stuffed up kermit
the frog
anyway
and now
it's just ridiculous
but here's the good news at least you
can save on your prescription allergy
medications all you got to do is go to
good rx because with good rx you can
compare prescription prices at over 70
000 pharmacies to help you find the best
price whether it's allergy medication or
anything else and you can even find
discounts of up to 80 percent good rx is
recommended by doctors pharmacists and
millions of people across the country
who have saved on their prescriptions
speaking of millions of people over 24
million used goodrx just last year to
save on their medications and you can
too whether that's on your allergy meds
or other prescriptions and remember even
if you have insurance goodrx could
actually beat your prescription copay
price yeah i mean i got i have great
insurance and i still
check good rx and
yeah you'd be surprised at how often the
prices on goodrx are better than the
prices that you get with your insurance
so for simple smart savings on your
prescriptions just go check goodrx you
all you got to do is go to goodrx.com
milkshake that's good
then the letters r and x
dot com slash milkshake good rx.com
milkshake good rx is not insurance it
can be used instead of insurance
medicare and medicaid indeed in 2021
good rx users saved 81 percent on retail
prescription prices
public goods is the one-stop shop for
sustainable high-quality everyday
essentials made from clean ingredients
at an affordable price everything from
personal care and household products to
coffee toilet paper shampoo pet food and
more public goods is your new everything
store thoughtfully designed for the
conscious consumer rather than buying
from a bunch of single product brands
public goods members can buy all of
their premium essentials in one place
with one beautiful streamlined aesthetic
public goods searches the globe to find
clean healthy eco-friendly and
innovative products yeah in our
household we have all these like public
good soap dispensers
i mean this is what i love about public
goods is that you know what's in your
products and you know where it came from
they ethically source and obsessively
develop each of their products to be
free of unhealthy ingredients and
harmful additives that are still common
on drug and grocery store shelves and
they're committed to making their
products healthy and safe for humans
animals and the environment this is how
they do it they have a membership model
and that's how they keep their costs low
and they can pass on even more savings
to their customers that way and best of
all you can make your first purchase
with no
obligation
join hundreds of thousands of others who
have switched to their new everything
store we've worked out an awesome deal
folks receive 15
15
off your first public goods order with
no minimum purchase that's right they
are so confident that you will
absolutely love their products and come
back again and again and again and again
that they are giving you 15 to spend on
your first purchase you got nothing to
lose just go to publicgoods.com
milkshake or use code milkshake at
checkout that is
g o o p-u-b-l-i-c-g-o-d s dot com
forward slash milkshake
to receive 15
off your first order
there's uh there's a thing that all of
our geek stories and i don't mean just
the three of us i mean all of us who
identify as geeks
all of our stories have two big things
in common one is here is a moment when i
was just so incredibly passionate and
excited and thrilled about this thing
that i loved and in the expression of
that
here is how i was humiliated by the
people around me who didn't get it okay
so with that in mind
also with um the understanding uh as
i've said before that being a nerd is
not about what you love it's about the
way you love a thing so here is my
giant massive are you kidding me nerd
story
um
i uh i work as a voice actor all the
time it is an a wonderful joyous part of
my career that i that i love and i
occasionally work at a studio
in uh
in burbank called out loud i was
finishing up one morning in uh out loud
and i was walking toward the door when
you get to the door there's a large kind
of kitchenette area where we all sit
with a long counter against the wall we
all sit at that counter and eat our
lunch or or or like drink our coffee or
whatever i'm walking down
the uh
the corridor to get to the door to leave
and there is a man sitting at the end of
the counter
and he is uh looking at an ipad and i
notice on the back of his neck a black
flag tattoo now i love the band black
flag i uh uh extremely influential very
very important to me in my development
as a human being punk rock is extremely
important to me it was
an enormous part of uh of shaping who i
am as a person and henry rollins in
particular who fronted black flag for
the majority of its of its uh uh
popularity um rollins is an amazing
writer he's an incredible dj uh uh he's
an activist i just i i love this man
like i i i worship this guy
and uh uh i say to this dude who's
sitting there with the black flag too on
the back tattoo on the back of his neck
oh my god i have been wanting to get one
of those black flag tattoos forever and
i just haven't pulled the trigger yet um
and before i can finish the second half
of that sentence this guy turns his head
and it's henry rollins
so
i
freeze
i
panic
i
say to him
oh my god you're henry rollins and he's
like yes i am and i say to him i'm gonna
do to you what sometimes happens to me
and i'm really sorry for this i know
that this that that this is weird
because i've been on i've been you in
this interaction and i go on like that
for i go on like that for a second right
just on and on and on and uh um uh i i
tell him how i read his books as poetry
in drama school and how i uh just
the music and what it means to me and
and and he's sort of looking at me kind
of puzzled and patient which is entirely
appropriate and the best i could have
hoped for this is when i realized that
i've been shaking his hand without
stopping for like close to 90 seconds
and i'm like okay i'm gonna leave uh i'm
sorry i'm sorry i hate this i'm sorry
i'm so mortified i'm gonna leave and i
go to and i hit the door i forget that
the door at out loud has a security
thing on it where you have to push a
button on the wall so the door will open
so i go like as hard as i can to push
through that door to go out into the
parking lot and i slam myself into the
wall right next to henry rollins and i'm
like oh uh
i'm sorry i okay uh no i i got i got
this uh um and uh and i push the door
again and the door doesn't open the
second time and one of the women who
works it out loud who 100 knows what's
going on is like you forgot to push the
button buddy i'm like okay thanks i
gotta i gotta push the button push
button i leave
i am
it's like i am i am so excited that i've
met henry rollins but also
absolutely mortified that i have
completely fallen apart in front of him
at this time i was still using twitter
and i recounted the story on twitter
from the parking lot and somebody said
oh you got to read the story that henry
wrote about one time when he met one of
his heroes and he just fell apart
exactly the same way you fell apart
henry will absolutely get that don't
worry about it what i what i love about
that story
is the way that it uh acknowledges the
intersection between geekhood and fandom
right yeah that there's
and and you were talking about very
clearly like in i remember like in the
70s and 80s like if you were a geek you
got beat up at school and now if you're
a geek you get to do marvel movies i
guess um yeah and so
things have changed but i think honestly
what's changed is
the way in which fandom uh has caught up
to to geek hood and and this is this is
a big part of this book which i which i
really love
but of course for you like growing up
being a part of uh not just like you
know a major franchise you know like
star trek but i mean you know one of
these kind of
game-changing earth-shattering uh uh
you know
things
um
i i wonder like how your relationship
with
fandom and with pop culture
has kind of ebbed and flowed over the
last
you know couple of decades in which
you've found yourself you know kind of
part of this gigantic thing
there's been good times and bad times
yeah for
all of my teens i was a target of toxic
fandom
and it really hurt a lot um i write
about in the book about being an abused
and exploited child when i was seven
years old my mother who was um
a
uh a
a commercial actor who had had a tiny
little bit of success but then just
just didn't keep up with the changes in
the industry when i was seven she
decided that i was going to be an actor
and she took me to her commercial agent
and she coached me to tell the agent i
want to do what mommy does
and uh i did what i was told because i
was seven and uh started going on
auditions and after uh
not very long
um i realized that i did not enjoy this
i didn't like it at all i didn't like
being in traffic every day after school
i didn't like getting home after the sun
had gone down because i was down in
hollywood doing auditions i didn't like
that i had to do my homework in the car
um
and i really didn't like that this was a
thing i absolutely did not want to do
and i vocalized that all the time and
neither of my parents would listen to me
um
my mom's gaslighting of me started
almost immediately
as long as i couldn't can remember she
told me it was my idea it was a thing
that i wanted to do and she gave up her
career for me
so by the time star trek came along
um i had had success in stand by me and
um i
had uh i had worked um i kind of worked
enough um to sort of show the industry
that i was reliable and that i was a
young person who could take direction
and and interpret scripts and things
like that and that's kind of like how i
ended up being on star trek and um
a constant through all of that in
addition to uh when i was when i was a
small kid my my dad was just kind of
like not interested in me um he was uh
uh dismissive of me
um the only time he ever really paid
attention to me was to humiliate me or
to mock me or uh to somehow put me down
and make me feel bad about myself so by
the time i was working on star trek
i was in an incredible amount of
existential pain i was lonely i was
afraid i had been in public high school
for a little bit in between stand by me
and star trek and
i was just universally bullied um i
think i had four friends out of a
student body of about a thousand um it
was terrible and it was really painful
the wesley crusher character um was
written in the first couple of seasons
of star trek as more of an idea than a
character and at least one original star
trek next generation writer hated the
character so much they kind of wrote him
badly
i suspect maybe on purpose um and i
can't prove it but it is something that
really matches up with a lot of stuff
i've experienced over the years um
and uh fans really hated him he was kind
of he was he was not well written he was
smarter than everybody uh he always
figured things out before the adults did
the adults never listened to him he was
always right um and they never showed
him being like a normal kid they never
showed him uh dealing with the things
that i was dealing with at that time
which was like yeah i'm very smart and
like can really work with you all in in
a professional environment but
when it's time to like go hang out after
work i have to go home and be alone
because i'm a kid and you're adults and
that created all this angst on we and me
and like we never saw wesley with his
friends and they corrected that in later
iterations of star trek they gave jake
cisco nog and uh and they've handled it
brilliantly and beautifully with adira
and gray in uh in star trek discovery um
they're handling it extraordinarily well
with cadet uhura in in strange new
worlds even though she's in her early
20s and wesley was a teenager so at that
time toxic fandom was
vicious and relentless and what i think
is real important for everybody to
remember is that these were adults
attacking a child yeah that's about a tv
show right
yeah and ruthlessly ruthlessly and by
the way this was before
social media like could you imagine way
before social media this was all on like
usernet and in the letters letter pages
of starlog people would come up to me at
star trek conventions and just be
unspeakably cruel to me um and then
demand my signature on a cast photo just
because they wanted it finished not be
you know really clear that they didn't
like me like um uh and it just felt like
nobody ever had my back yeah my parents
certainly didn't um my cast had my back
but i never really talked to them about
that aspect of things um they were there
for me emotionally they showed up for me
emotionally on the set but it's not like
i could go to someone's dressing room
and say i really need to have a heart to
heart with you about this stuff because
i didn't know how to do that i didn't
have those skills so that is the toxic
fandom that i
experienced um
right around the time the internet was
really becoming
mainstream having gone through all of
that and experienced all of that it's a
thing that i feel really strongly about
and uh um i feel like a lot of us
that came of age through that
have worked
to try and keep
kindness and and the and the reminder
that there's a human being on the other
side of the screen in the front of
people's minds but like
it's just hard like we are not the
loudest voice in the room and there's
just not a lot we can do about it right
now so we were the we we're the same age
well i just turned 50 and so
i was your age while you were
you know wesley crusher
and
and you know being being a fan like i i
mean i remember hearing all of that
stuff all of that negativity um
and then yeah then like after a few
seasons you know uh the the character
you know kind of disappears and goes off
to
to starfleet and i wonder because you
were talking about how in the later
seasons now there's the internet and
things are different and there's already
the transition coming in almost in a way
uh the way that your character was
handled is reflective of that because
then when you start then when wesley
started coming back like those are some
kick-ass episodes okay like the the
kovald starburst that is a kick ass
episode yeah those episodes were written
by writers who loved him and understood
him and and were really supported in
in telling his story um
i recently watched my very very last
episode and it was hard to watch all i
see in myself is just so much sadness
just overwhelming like if sadness were a
noise you would have to mute the tv
because it was overwhelming for me
um but those episodes were very very
well written
um and i'm really happy you know i um
uh
i i love ron moore who wrote journeys
and said he always felt like wesley
crusher was meant to do something
different from starfleet he said he
always felt like the rigidity of
starfleet and and the the rules and
regulations aspect of it was not kind of
his thing he wanted to do something else
and and uh he thought well the traveler
told picard that wesley could do these
other things and he was destined for
more and like picard ought to be
supportive of that and his mother ought
to be supportive of that and i really
loved that aspect of that story because
i didn't have that support yeah it's
just kind of talking about your own
parents yeah i love this place where i
am now in my professional life where i
host the ready room for the star trek
universe because very much like wesley
crusher
we both like kind of left our starships
because we had been put on paths that we
figured out weren't necessarily right
for us
it didn't mean that we didn't love the
people we were around when we were there
and it doesn't mean that
we didn't do great things when we were
there it just means
this is not the thing and he went with
the traveler for
30 years
and i went
essentially to therapy for 30 years
and and uh and now the two of us have
come back to star trek at this moment
where
where as this traveler he brings this
wisdom and this experience and uh uh and
uh um and a perspective from outside of
the universe looking in that the other
characters don't have
i can do that too
i can do that as as someone who is you
know there's there's only one show
that's older than ours that is the
weirdest thing for me to think of i just
keep thinking about how like my friends
who are on enterprise have been like
yeah that was a long time ago and i'm
like don't talk to me about a long time
ago let me tell you about a long time
ago
and um and i and i really uh i really i
i love that um
and i'm so grateful for this
relationship that i as a human and
beginning to have with these actors who
play the characters on these other shows
um because i interviewed them for ready
room and they want to talk to me about
okay buddy you've been on part of star
trek for three decades like can we have
a lot of questions and i'm just like i'm
here for it i'm here for everything you
want to know like i let me support you
and and and love your shows
and finding out i didn't know this but
finding out a couple of weeks ago that
multiple star trek series kind of went
to war over who got wesley
um
was really validating and wonderful for
me and the celebration from fandom over
the last few weeks
has been beautiful and wonderful and i
just wish you know
i wish that i could go back in time and
grab 15 16 year old me and just hug him
and tell him this sucks and this has
nothing to do with you
and there is a time in your future where
as much as you are feeling hated right
now
you are going to feel loved
in a way that you almost that you will
not be able to understand that's how
much love is going to come to you that's
how much celebration is going to come to
you uh it's so gratifying to hear you
say that because
i relate to that story
in so many different ways and it's kind
of where we wanted to bring this
conversation which was
you know for me growing up that nerd
that i uh previously encapsulated in in
suburban seattle and then i went i fell
in love with acting in theater but in a
really nerd way it's like it's how you
love it how i love theater was yeah you
know reading everything by bertral
brecht until three in the morning you
know and
um
and so went off to acting school
and still you know as an actor you're
not supposed to be a nerdy geek you're
supposed to be able to play
you know hamlet and do
you play all different kinds of roles
and lead roles and although hamlet
that's actually a pretty geeky character
but yeah i
i went through some transitions in my
kind of really awkward uh early and
mid-20s where
eventually after
really hitting my head against the
concrete on some in some with some bad
performances i came around to realizing
in my late 20s early 30s
hey
i'm that same geeky suburban kid from
seattle now being an actor this is who i
am i am
i'm intellectual i read science fiction
um i study world religions and mythology
i'm interested in um
spirituality i'm interested in you know
tech
uh
i
i get my clothes at thrift stores
and i'm awkward socially and i'm kind of
weird in my body
and and [ __ ] it this is who i need to be
as an actor i'm not going to be some
kind of like
juilliard train kind of like
you know larger than life leading man
and um you know and be built and and
and you know uh and charming that's just
that's not who i am and in embracing
that
um
that enabled me to later on play dwight
schrute because yeah it was a deep
understanding of who someone like dwight
schrute was and drawing on those roots
back from my suburban seattle years but
also from
you know
embracing who i was and you have
embraced who you are you've embraced
your history you've found this kind of
identity you know they have like gay
icons right like lady gaga well you're
in the top five geek icons but you went
through a really difficult painful
treacherous journey to get there but one
thing i really loved about your book is
like
i can just see this book just
poured over
by the the geeks of america because it's
it's so unabashed and proud and
um and at the same time
one of the things that i feel like you
have discovered and i hope that i have
as well is that you have a big heart
so yeah it's not
just the geekdom of the kind of nerdy
lists of esoteric knowledge that you
have in your in your brain stem it's
really like
you've learned the value of deep
kindness and empathy and your efforts to
combat bullying so
here's two geeks made good
embracing their identity and going on a
journey when we grow into ourselves
whenever that happens when we finally
feel like i talk about having like
feeling like my feet are underneath me
feeling feeling like like like i'm i'm
really connected to
whatever reality um when those moments
happen
um
i
i i feel like um
i feel like i am making choices and i'm
doing things kind of like on purpose
um uh to do you know what's important to
me
and the people who
are really
genuinely supportive who are genuinely
the people you know we want to have in
our lives i don't know what it's been
like for you guys but as i've gotten
older my friend group has gotten
substantially smaller
especially through the pandemic like
it's gone exponentially smaller we
figure out like these are the
relationships that we absolutely cannot
live without these are the relationships
that are very nice to have and these are
the relationships that just aren't worth
maintaining
and um
i found that when i
wanted to just walk away from this thing
that i didn't like
i was supported by the people that
mattered
and i was unsupported by the people who
were benefiting because
i was doing that thing
and uh
one of the things i hope people will get
out of
this book
is maybe like a little bit of a road map
a little bit of a level guide a little
bit of a frequently asked questions list
to help get started
as
as as you unnamed person who i don't
know who you are
kind of starts down this
this journey of
of questioning and and ultimately
realizing who you are and what's
important to you
and um to bring it kind of around to how
this relates to the into like it
intersects with being a geek um
you know for the longest time we were
told that we should be ashamed of loving
science we should we should be
embarrassed because uh uh we liked
classical music we you know we sh we we
shouldn't care about chess we shouldn't
care about science fiction uh you know
all that matters is how hard you can hit
somebody you know in various forms and
stuff and um
i i feel like we're just
saying to everybody when
when you
realize that you're a nerd don't let
anybody tell you that's not okay you're
not hurting anybody at all
and i think that that ultimately
what matters is
um to choose an abundance of kindness
and to choose love support and and uh
and celebration of people who are doing
things they love that are not hurting
other people
this is i mean such a beautiful message
and and the book uh i think in talking
about your life and all the ups and
downs that you have had um and
maintaining true to yourself right is
making sure that
that despite the fact that you know
there are people who are attacking you
that the people that are supposed to
love you and support you are doing none
of those things um that you kind of held
on to the core of who you are even when
you feel like an outsider in your own
life and it's it's such an inspiring
story uh and it was such an absolute
thrill
to have you on the pod will wheaton
thank you so so much for joining us it's
been oh it's been such a pleasure i've
really loved talking to both of you
thank you yeah this has been absolutely
fantastic thanks will
i have to say that uh that was really
really inspiring
even more uplifting than i thought
really uh exceptional conversation and
um
you know i feel uh i feel really
invigorated
yeah
i mean just like hearing him
suddenly now i mean i guess he's 50 so
you're supposed to be this by the time
you're 50 but he's so comfortable in his
skin he's so comfortable about the
decisions that he's made he's got you
know
no regrets about all the things that
have happened to him and and again like
it's hard for us to imagine as a
teenager
you know going through what he went
through
and coming out of it the way that he did
like he should be like either dead or
like a a crack dealer on the street or
something that's that's the way these
stories usually end i just want to say
for all our listeners out there uh and
all of our viewers uh all 817 of you on
our youtube channel listen
um
this is your chance let this episode uh
fill you with a purpose and a meaning
having to do with embracing who you are
all of your oddness all of your
eccentricity all of your imbalances your
awkwardness yes
um
whether you're
gay or lesbian
or uh whether you're on the spectrum
whether you're a super nerd whether no
in whichever way you have never fit into
the norm
you know what
[ __ ] them
this is our chance all of us to embrace
our inner oddness and
the world will be made a better place
once we all do that that's right be who
you are people be who you are everyone
else is taken
that's a good one and uh you know we uh
have a little giveaway here too we have
five tops five
of will wheaton's very heavy
uh
book it is still just a geek an
annotated uh memoir and we're gonna give
five of these away to our listeners you
know how easy this is all you got to do
is go to apple podcast write us a review
take a screenshot of the review send it
in to us you can find us on social media
at reza aslan rayne wilson on twitter at
metamilkpodcast or on instagram at
metaphysical milkshake you could even uh
email it to us what's our email address
it is metaphysical at castmedia.com
metaphysical cast media.com that's cast
with a k
send us uh send us some kind of proof uh
of your review and guess what we're
gonna do we're gonna send you will's
book and especially for those of you out
there uh whether you're young or old or
in between and you're struggling with
uh who people tell you you should be
and who you actually are
my co-host rayne wilson said it best
[ __ ] the haters there you have it thanks
for listening folks follow rate review
metaphysical milkshake on apple podcasts
wherever else you listen to podcasts
please subscribe to our metaphysical
milkshake youtube channel
and watch our full episodes unfold every
week see you next week metaphysical
milkshake is executive produced by rayne
wilson reza aslan and colin thompson it
is produced by safa samazadeh yazd
harris lane mick dimaria hashem himself
and dj
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
i think that darmok could be a lot of
things it also sounds like a dish you
eat somewhere that is amazing while
you're eating it and then at roughly 18
hours later you really regret diving
like just getting elbow deep into darmok
shakka when the walls fell if you know
what i mean
reza that was one of the best uses of
shock open the wall
i've heard it in a really long time
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you